MILITARY HAS BEEN SENT TO FIGHT
WILDFIRES AND ONE OF THE
COLDEST PLACES ON EARTH.
MORE THAN 2 AND A HALF MILLION
HECTARES HAVE BURNED IN SIBERIA
SO FAR THIS YEAR.
CNN'S KIM BRUNHUBER REPORTS.
FROM HIGH ABOVE RUSSIAN
MILITARY AIRCRAFT DROPPED
HUNDREDS OF TONS OF WATER ON
THE ANGRY FLAMES BELOW.
THEY ARE IN A BATTLE AGAINST
WILDFIRES THAT ARE RAVAGING
NORTHEASTERN SIBERIA.
IN AN AREA MORE ACCUSTOMED TO
ARCTIC TEMPERATURES, RESIDENTS
ARE FACING ENORMOUS BLAZES AND
THAWING LAND THAT HAS BEEN
FROZEN FOR CENTURIES.
RISING TEMPERATURES AND THE
SUFFOCATING SMOKE OR DRIVING
RESIDENTS AND FIREFIGHTERS TO
DIG TRENCHES TO KEEP THE FIRE
AWAY FROM THEIR HOMES AND FEELS,
BUT THE SMOG IS ALREADY COVERED
OVER 50 SETTLEMENTS DISRUPTING
DAILY LIFE.
THE SITUATION SITUATION IS
PARTICULARLY DIRE FOR THE
ELDERLY AND COVID-19 PATIENTS
WERE FEELING HOPELESS AND
SCARED.
>> IT'S FRIGHTENING.
SMOKE EVERY DAY, JUST EVERY DAY.
ONLY TODAY WE HAVE A LITTLE.
SUN >> ABNORMALLY HIGH
TEMPERATURES, DROUGHT AND HIGH
WINDS HAVE WORSENED THE SPREAD
OF THE FIRE, ACCORDING TO MEDIA
REPORTS.
PEOPLE IN NORTHEASTERN SIBERIA
RAIL RELY ON THESE FOR US.
WHEN IT BURNS, WOODS TURNED
INTO SWAMPS IN THE FLAMMABLE,
DRY UNDERGROWTH RELEASES LONG
STORIED CARBON INTO THE.
AIR >> THE FIRE HAZARD
SITUATION HAS SHARPLY WORSENED
ALMOST ALL OVER THE COUNTRY TO
THE ABNORMAL HEAT.
THE SITUATION HERE IS THE MOST
DIFFICULT.
>> SO FAR, FLAMES HAVE RIPPED
THROUGH THOUSANDS OF HECTARES
OF RUSSIAN FOREST.
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE GROUND AND
IN THE AIR OR TRYING TO
EXTINGUISH THE BLAZES AND STOP
THEM FROM SPREADING, A THICK
SMOKE CUTS OFF VISIBILITY.
>> FIRE IS MASSIVE.
WE EXTINGUISH IT IN ONE PLACE
AN ADDICT IGNITES IN ANOTHER.
IT IS VERY HOT WEATHER.
THE FIRE IS STILL STRONG
FANNING THE FIRE QUICKLY.
WHAT >> WHAT IS ONE OF THE
COLDEST PLACES ON EARTH HAS NOW
BECOME ONE OF THE FASTEST
WARMING REGIONS.
SCIENTISTS SAY THAT WHILE
OCCASIONAL FIRE FOREST FIRES
ARE NORMAL, FOREST FIRES IN
NORTH AMERICA AND RUSSIA ARE
BURNING AT UNPRECEDENTED RATES.
>> WHAT'S COMMON WITH THESE
FIRES THAT THEY ARE RECURRING
IN PLACES WHERE THERE ARE HEAT
WAVE CONDITIONS, THEIR
LONG-STANDING DROUGHT
CONDITIONS, AND THESE THINGS
ALL FEED INTO WHAT WE CALL THE
FLAMMABILITY A FUEL.
>> AS A CHANGING CLIMATE WREAKS
HAVOC, ANOTHER POPULATION HAS
BEEN FORCED TO RECKON WITH THE
WARMING WORLD.
KIM BRUNHUBER, CNN.
>> LET'S GO TO DEREK VAN DAM,
SENIOR METEOROLOGIST WITH MORE
ON THE SITUATION SEE GLOBAL
RISING TEMPERATURES AND WE CAN
EXPECT.
>> KIM WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW
THE ARCTIC IS WARMING FASTER
THAN THE REST OF THE PLANET OF
THE ARCTIC WARMING PLANET
PROGRAM WE'VE SUMMARIZE SOME OF
THE FINDINGS.
THEY FOUND AT THE ARCTIC IS
WARM 3 TIMES AS FAST AS THE
GLOBAL AVERAGE TEMPERATURE.
BASICALLY A 50 YEAR PERIOD 19
71 TO 2019, THAT IS A HOT SPOT
FOR GLOBAL CLIMATE CHANGE IN
THE NORTHERN HALF OF OUR
PLANET.
THIS IS AMONGST THE BACKDROP OF
SEVERAL AREAS OF THE WORLD TO
HAVE WILDFIRES BURNING OUT OF
CONTROL.
SUB AREA YOU SAW, THE WESTERN
U.S., 78 LARGE ACTIVE FIRES IN
THAT AREA, INCLUDING THE 4TH
LARGEST WILDFIRE IN OREGON
STATE HISTORY.
WE TALK ABOUT 160,000 HECTARES
BURNING ONLY 38% CONTAINMENT.
WHICH IS GOOD BECAUSE THEY'RE
STARTING TO MAKE SOME GROUNDS
ON THIS FIRE.
THE WEATHER HAS TURNED SLIGHTLY
COOLER, THE WINDS HAVE DROPPED,
SO THERE HAS BEEN SOME
IMPROVEMENT, BUT NONETHELESS,
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF SMOKE BILLOWING FROM THESE
FOREST FIRES INCLUDING THE
MOVEMENT OF FIRE ACROSS CENTRAL
OREGON.
WHY AM I SHOWING A PICTURE OF A
STATUE OF LIBERTY.
BECAUSE IT'S SHROUDED IN CLOUDS
OF SMOKE FROM PARTS OF THE
U.S..
IT GETS LOFTED INTO THE UPPER
LEVELS OF THE ATMOSPHERE,
TRANSFERRED TRANSPORTED ACROSS
CONTINENTS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THE EAST COAST
IS GOING TO CLEAR OUT TODAY.
THE BAD NEWS IT IS THAT THE
FOREST FIRES ARE STILL
BILLOWING SMOKE.
IT'S GONNA CREATE HAZY
CONDITIONS AND DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS FROM PEOPLE FROM
MINNEAPOLIS, ON THE WAY TO
CHICAGO TO INDIANAPOLIS.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE SIZE OF
COMBUSTIBLE COMBUSTION
PARTICLES SUCH AS SMOKE, AND
THE POLLUTION THAT WE EMIT FROM
OUR VEHICLES, IT'S ABOUT 2 AND
A HALF MIKE RUNS IN DIAMETER.
THAT IS SIGNIFICANTLY SMALLER
THAN THE DIAMETER OF YOUR HUMAN
AIR, SO IT HAS THE ABILITY TO
LODGE ITSELF DEEP WITHIN YOUR
LUNGS.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE WITH
RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS HAVE
ISSUES WITH SMOG AND SMOKE.
YOU SEE THE POOR AIR QUALITY
ACROSS MUCH OF THE U.S..
WE ARE AT OUR HIGH LEVEL OF
WILDFIRE ALERT LEVEL ACROSS THE
U.S. WESTERN U.S. IN MORE THAN
A DECADE.
JOHN?
>> THAT SMOG IS SO FINE IT CAN
MAKE IT TO MOST OF THE SPACE
MASKS THE PEOPLE WEAR.
AS DEREK THANK YOU APPRECIATE.
IT WILL FROM FIRE TO FLOODS TO
THIS.
IT'S A DUST DEVIL A PROBLEM IN
BOLIVIA.
PLAYERS WERE CAUGHT BY SURPRISE
AS IT ROLLED AND DURING A LOCAL
FOOTBALL MATCH TUESDAY.
NO REPORTS OF ANYONE BEING HURT.